[Music]
okay everybody so this is my spoiler
review of the yellow jackets finale
written by show runners ashley lyle and
bart nickerson and this is directed by
eduardo sanchez so like i did last week
i'm going to break down my review into
two parts we'll start with the present
day storyline and then we'll go to
what's going on in the woods okay so i
love the present day starts with misty
here and she's got this caligula bag
that says don't ruffle my feathers which
was great and i think competing with the
funny line of the book club line with
jeff it has to be this line in the
beginning here with misty where she's
like oh no gloria and they're like yeah
she had another stroke and she says she
was so young and the nurse goes she was
89.
that was amazing and the show does such
a good job of just throwing in little
humorous lines and a very dark show in
itself and there's something obviously
so enjoyable about misty and
particularly christina richie's
portrayal of her in present day and
what you love about this character of
misty is she is absolutely insane but
she's still so damn likable and even
when she's mentioning to nat in the car
the terms of their deal and you actually
realize what the deal is is that misty
is agreeing to get rid of a dead body
for nat just so she'll go to the reunion
and i love that that goes on throughout
this episode that misty while all the
other three women are nervous about the
reunion have all these emotional
feelings misty's just excited to be with
her friends she's talking about how she
went out drinking at this reunion they
had fun and she's hung over
it really is a great written character
now before misty and nat arrived to
adams where shanna and taissa are with
adam's dead body there is a very
interesting shot where shauna's looking
down at the blood that is soaking
through now through the dead body of
adam and they make a big point of that
of her looking at that and it also to me
connects to the moment in the woods this
episode where shaun is just about to eat
some of the bare blood and one of the
girls was like you know don't eat that
like you'll get sick and
as this episode goes on more and more
i'm just like you know shauna to me is
like
it's synergy for showtime basically
because she's like dexter you know we
get to see even cut up a body this
episode and she doesn't get affected by
it you know she has those kind of serial
killer tendencies where she can easily
kill
animals and again this like craving for
blood so i think that's fascinating
again it could also allude to her
eventually probably eating people and
again just great humorous moments
between these great actresses is when
shawn is like really nat you know your
big plan is bringing misty here and she
says it's in front of misty you know and
misty's like how about how have you been
hi and thanks for helping us cover up a
murder i i just thought that was so
great okay so a really important scene
is with shauna and nat here and nat is
still pushing at shauna about you know
like hey if he's a blackmailer what's
the deal like who killed travis right
did he at least know somebody and
it's interesting because we know shauna
is lying to nat and tyson's face about
who the actual blackmailer is and that
we know it's actually her husband jeff
but i do truly believe shauna here when
she's basically saying that you know i
don't believe there is a conspiracy here
and that travis yeah just killed himself
and she's like i know what it's like the
numbness paranoia sometimes i look at
the world and it's like all the light is
gone out of it maybe travis couldn't
stand to live like that anymore and
maybe you need to start trying to
forgive him so shawn is saying this
which she really i believe truly
believes but she also obviously wants
nat off her tail about the blackmailing
kind of forget about it so it doesn't go
back to jeff but
this sets up for the episode natalie
going to a really dark place and
actually it's shauna saying this stuff
that's like
you know putting nats
hope for some things up here you know
that travis wouldn't do this and someone
killed him down and it's putting her in
a bad place and i thought that was
really well written here and i do think
with the show i wasn't i haven't been
too crazy about the present-day
storyline this episode its strength was
how good the present-day story was here
and how much hope it gives me for season
two which we'll get into and i mean i
can't praise enough how much great
humorous lines they had here with misty
where she's like i just had the craziest
case of deja vu while she's cleaning up
blood like of course misty would say
that so misty's great plan here was
actually to take the hands in the head
of adam and how to get rid of those like
she said the most important part to get
rid of was throwing those in gloria's
casket and having them cremated so that
was set up really well and there's a
little thing they throw in here on
second watch when i watch it that like
misty mentions really quickly to them
she's taking all of adam's journals and
stuff and his books so she's definitely
gonna rummage through all that and
that's gonna be interesting that's
definitely gonna be a plot line for
season two again what i'm talking about
where they're really setting up the
present day to be much better for next
season now there's a really
strong
little mini montage here between the
three leading ladies here with taissa
shauna and nat and
we see shauna's crying in the shower
right and this is almost in a way
subconsciously getting us ready for
shauna by the end of this episode their
big moment with jackie
it's also showing us i think the first
two times we've seen shauna even cry in
this show and it's in the present day
and in the past so i thought it was
really
smart they saved that for the finale and
had them both appear in both stages and
i also like how it was cutting between
taissa coming home also crying but to an
empty house that she's losing her family
here and that like i said prior is
already clearly in a dark head space but
i like this in particular so much with
shauna because i'm someone like i said
my previous reviews that i am not a fan
of the character shauna i am team jackie
all the way but this episode is the
first one that made me like shauna more
because i saw more humanity in her and
everything we've seen about her some of
the crazy stuff she does at the end of
the day you see how much she does
actually feel guilt about what happened
to jackie and how much she loves jackie
and back at her from jackie so
what makes shows and tvs great i've said
this in other reviews i'm gonna say it
again it's great relationships and the
core of season one
is the relationship between shauna and
jackie and i like down the finale they
gave it a nice little bow as a payoff
that that was going to be the focus here
we were going to get it resolved and see
how that ended how it's going to affect
shauna going forward and i think they
did a really good job of doing that now
when our three ladies show up to the
reunion i love that misty's already
there and she just jumps into their like
big moment where they're all walking in
together looking cool and it's always
great to have offspring playing uh that
gives you a point up just on that alone
and again like you see how they're all
so on edge and this is a very emotional
thing for them to even be there but
misty's just excited to take pictures
now one of my favorite multi episode and
this is obviously how great an actress
juliette lewis is is when there's this
haunting sad score
under her when she's looking at the
display like trophy case of the soccer
team of the yellow jackets and looking
at a picture of travis just with the
acting on her face seeing where she's at
and it's really sad and it's sad because
we'll even see her make a toast a couple
minutes later about her close friends
and i do believe here this is where
she's thinking like tonight's the night
like that she's going to kill herself
now we also see which we learned last
episode that randy walsh is the only
other person besides jeff and shauna
that knows jeff is the blackmailer but
randy walsh realizes right away that
shauna knows by her body language and
then she just basically threatens him
and is like i will gut you like a pig if
you talk and shauna means this like
that's what's awesome about this show is
they've written a character that yeah
like when those kind of lines you've
seen the shows before come out they
don't actually mean exactly literally
what they're saying but shauna does and
what it makes me think is that randy is
someone who clearly will slip up he is a
goofball and i think if he does i don't
think he'll ruin it for sean i think
he's just gonna be killed by shauna for
sure and again i just love little lines
they always contribute in the show that
serves the character and learning more
about the character or just fits with
the character there's no waste to it and
that's even just taissa here just a nice
little reminder to the audience whenever
she's sitting at the table's like if one
more person tells me i'm in their
thoughts and prayers like upset about it
because again remember taissa throughout
this whole story is never been the
believer she's not the one into the
supernatural and even in present day
she's still not someone who just
believes in it now the taissa that is
having her episodes that's a whole
different story i'm talking about the
taissa that's consciously aware of what
she's doing now ally she's a class chair
and she was a member of the
yellowjackets that wasn't actually on
the flight with but was supposed to be
now i don't trust her at all i think
we're purposely not to trust her she is
annoying purposefully and
also you have to look at the framing
here maybe i'm looking too much into
this but where it says on the
presentation behind her 1996 she is
covering that six with her body it is
perfectly lined up with the upside down
sticks is next to her it made me think
of 666 that it's giving you a sign this
woman is literally like the devil
because also just from seeing her for a
few moments she is clearly like envious
she wasn't on the flight in a way in a
sick way that she wants some of that
glory that they have and it even shows
like how just like this is her thing
this slideshow like the way she presents
it with the enya and it leads to this
extremely awkward jeff and shauna having
to dance in front of a picture of jackie
but i love they blended this and cut it
through with the past time on with sean
and jackie's big moment and showing
shawna's guilt there but we'll get to
that so let's go the next morning and
you see misty like i was saying before
she's like
excited about how the night when she's
telling jessica like yeah we had shots
hanging out with old friends you know
i'm a little hungover
and of course she has a caliglia mug and
what i love about this mug it's not just
a bird mug it's a custom calliglia mug
she had made with the picture of her
actual bird i thought that was great you
know let's get that yellow jackets
merchandise made for us in the real
world it's already on urban outfitters
some of the stuff that's been selling
out quick but don't buy from them
they're the devil they their prices are
ridiculously overpriced so let's wait
till like hot topic makes it and i love
the line jessica calling it the caligula
inn but you knew this second misty
handed jessica those cigarettes that
they were poisoned that's her mo misty
but what's so fascinating about and i'm
talking about again how it's setting up
season two for the present storyline to
be really good is that there's all these
inner secrets between the main
characters here and that
we know that jessica was hired by taissa
to see if anyone was going to speak and
for misty to now poison her and i assume
she might be dead but she might actually
still be alive that's gonna be
interesting when tyson finds out that
you know jessica was poisoned at least
so how misty knows that and shauna's
hiding in the black metal thing so we
got a lot of things people aren't
telling each other so taise is actually
convinced she's not gonna win she's
preparing a concession speech while
she's on the phone with simone and but
what's interesting simone mentioned
sammy's on a play date with a kid named
elvis i feel like that's what's gonna
make reddit go crazy like why who is
this elvis you know why is he named
elvis but again it's just showing you
this sad state taissa is in before she
gets a big win here which we'll get to
so like i was saying last episode jeff
and sean it looks like now they're gonna
be closer than ever and it definitely
happens here when they're sitting on the
couch watching tv
and sean is like i think we should get a
cat and jeff's like well i hope this cat
behaves itself or i'll end up in the
chili pot i mean how much of a psycho is
jeff that he's kind of like just cool
that he didn't end up in the woods
starving and we know he read the journal
so i guess jeff and sean are really are
a perfect match and then again this
could be something looking way too into
it but it could also mean something else
too where shawn is now thinking about
getting a cat after misty just helped
them so maybe misty is growing on her
because misty is the cat lady and maybe
by jeff saying i hope this cat behaves
itself or end up in the chili pot could
also mean that you know if misty does
cross shauna at any point that shawna
will actually be misty's end and cali is
just like what the hell is going on
because she knows a lot of the dirty
laundry between the two of them and now
she sees them really close
and what i love is that cali sees on tv
that adam is missing so
cali and simone here what they do so
good about their characters is now they
have learned information that is huge
and it makes them like randy walsh
variables for what can go on between
these adults in the current timeline and
it's going to be interesting how shauna
handles cali in general that intrigues
me a lot and back to simone right one of
my favorite moments of this episode was
her in the basement
finding dice is like
feeding dungeon here and at the same
time they're cutting between taissa
winning the elections surprisingly and
becoming the senator taista turner and
we see the dog that she ate which a lot
of people predicted which was crazy and
the sammy doll there and the symbol and
like i'm saying all this stuff is just
fascinating stuff that simone found this
out setting up really great seeds for
season two and i was so scared because
before we go into the past we know
jackie dies right but because this
jackie tragedy is like happening cutting
between when that's about to shoot
yourself i'm like oh my god are we going
to lose nat and current day too i was
like can't lose juliette lewis now we
need her and it was such a good trick
because it sounded like the gun went off
but it was actually just a knock at the
door but it's a group of people kidnap
her with the symbol on their necklace
and there you go the phone starts
ringing when they take her it's too late
and it was susie that's former sponsor
who looked into the bank account and
there's your big reveal that lottie
matthews is the one who definitely
killed travis and was the one taking the
money out of the bank account so she
lives lottie she is not pick girl and is
this going to be the casting of the
century or what i mean
any working actress right now is
probably calling their agent seeing if
they can get get an audition at least to
play adult lottie and i'd love to hear
your guys down below who you think
should be adult lottie and susie too she
says she thinks someone's following her
so i'm sure susie knows this information
she's gonna be killed probably episode
one next season and it's a great cut to
lottie this reveal in the snow in the
past but we'll get to that because now
we'll shift over to the whole past
storyline from the top so in the past
right they're waking up from this crazy
night and moment they had on these
shrooms and there's so much to be said
about the visual shot here of shauna
picking up the knife and when she's
looking at it confused in the foreground
in the background you have lottie behind
her almost smirking with mari a little
further back and
what this really tells me too is it
really serves a lot of that theory i
really like going on on reddit that
yes it's pretty much confirmed at this
point especially this episode that
lottie is the antler queen but that
there could be a passing of that to a
secondhand queen and that it's shauna
and that they've given so many visual
clues to shauna being the antler queen
and that that shot visually to me could
be that influence lottie has over shauna
now we see that nat is in the woods and
finds travis to make sure he's okay and
he's looking for javi and
it's interesting because
it would have changed everything if
travis and nat were with the main camp
and it would have changed what happened
with jackie they would have been on
jackie's side even though yes nat would
still be obviously kind of pissed to
jackie but
at that moment the more important thing
is travis what happened to travis and
it was smart by the writers to have to
kind of
get where they needed to be but it was
justified that nat would do that first
because in my head it's looking like
where we left off the last episode it's
kind of weird that
no nat didn't directly stay there and
confront lottie
that to me feels a little bit like a
cheat for sure so it's not all perfect
transition but for where we start in
this episode that part makes sense and
also misty here is reading this black
book with like a picture of a deer head
on it so i wonder what that book is it
was probably in this
somewhat cursed cabin here
and i wonder what she's learning in
there misty and you see jackie comes out
fighting with the girls and then
everyone realizes misty drug them but
what comes in is this bear it's also
interesting too is that when the bear
comes out and then lottie's the one who
takes the knife to go kill it this bear
kind of bows down to lottie which to me
really serves the supernatural like that
yeah there is something supernatural
happening for sure because maybe this
bear is sensing that that there's
something in the air there but what i do
love about this show is again you can't
just fully say it's definitely
supernatural because again you can still
justify so much of it by lottie having
visions not taking her meds them being
starving whatever they're eating et
cetera et cetera so i like to show kind
of toys with you like that and even that
visions that people are seeing could
just be dreams and this one's talking
about what's crazy about this character
of misty is that when she's going to try
to help cook with the bear mari's like
no we're not trusting you food and then
she says f off to misty i don't know you
guys i felt bad for misty here and it's
weird that i feel bad for her but again
she's just so damn likable you you like
misty she's like the complete opposite
of lottie cause they both will pretty
much do anything like they're do awful
things but misty
her intentions are that she just wants
to be liked you know she wants to be
friends with everybody where lottie's
just
completely like
possessed you know and just not really a
good bone in her so far so what's
important is van i love the scene where
she's talking to taissa about the
incident that happened with her and the
wolf and she's like before she thought
she was gonna die she saw something i
don't think i was dead but i don't think
i was alive either it's like this in
between she says and to me this could be
which we're gonna get to because there's
there's a lot going on in the scene with
shauna and jackie when jackie dies but i
feel like jackie was having this
experience that van had
before she froze to death in that
montage seeing the man in the cabin and
then it wasn't shauna dreaming or maybe
there was still a connection there but
we'll get into that but see ty who's
always gonna be the doubter here's like
you were in shock and the way acts this
you're just like there's no way it's
gonna work for these two now they're
complete opposites on this stuff and
they're hardcore opposites like van is
really in now almost as much as lottie
and ty is not and they give ty just i'm
talking these quick great humorous lines
van you believe that sporty spice is the
most underrated spice girl and you know
what van's right there i'll give her
that and visually too with van the way
they've
done the makeup with her and the scar
she has it reminds me of the chucky doll
nobody else because she also got the red
hair going so
it makes me think clearly that
she is going to be a monster at the end
of this and that
she is in this clearly in the lottie
crew and i think confirmed in this
episode for sure that lottie van
and mari are in this crew of lottie and
this believing this entity while misty
in the beginning at least is with them
but again what's so cool and interesting
about this character misty is she you
know just goes to the floor she doesn't
really i don't think believe in the
stuff she goes with it ever again where
she fits in and is light so misty
someone again who's gonna i think
throughout the story flip and flop and
go to different sides and clearly
because misty we know yeah the other
episode she's bowing behind lottie but
misty's still even to be in the presence
of natalie
taissa and shauna you know i don't think
she stayed there i think she eventually
is with them or they wouldn't be near
her so we see it their bare feasts here
that you see van is like lottie you said
we would have food now we do basically
and jackie's like come on that's just
luck and van's the one even suggesting a
grace here so this is like a first taste
of these rituals that are clearly going
to start happening and i love when
they're joining hands and reaching out
mr goes to reach out for jackie that was
great and quick plug i just interviewed
the actress of young misty and samantha
hanrady it was a blast
talked to her this week so please check
out the interview it's linked below you
see they're giving thanks now the spirit
of the bear and jackie's just like what
the hell is going on this one i'm
talking about where you wish you know
maybe a nat or travis was here to kind
of speak some sense into these people
right and tais is muted right now
because she's just playing with it to
look you know safe face in front of anne
and you know she can't just speak up at
this moment but you see now jackie leans
into the elephant in the room about what
exactly happened with travis and this
leads to the much awaited showdown
between shauna and jackie and they're
airing it all out and again there's
great lines here between the two of them
amazing performances by them and
you know what like you you whatever side
you're on sean and jackie are neither
like they're both saying truth here
they're both a little wrong and a little
right and
i think that's why it's such a good
relationship and so realistic and at the
end of the day they love each other you
know and it makes it so tragic the
ending of it and you wish you didn't get
to that level of fighting and i think it
goes to that crossed moment when shauna
says that you peeked in high school line
like
that's where it like went past them just
saying kind of truthful things they had
to get out and went to like just
seriously being mean by shauna i still
hate shawna and i'm gonna miss ella
purnell like crazy like i you know i'm
sure they're gonna have her in
flashbacks maybe even time before they
got to the woods so
it is just the unfortunate thing we have
a death like this that you lose a great
actress in the show as a regular and
when i'm talking about setting up this
group that's more evil you know
the coach even steps in here when he's
like we can't just have jackie go
outside but you see lottie and mari are
really like no it's fine you know so
like again
those three and van it's just they're
scaring me right now and what really is
going to drive sean is guilt we see here
too is that tais even said to shawna
when jackie was out there she got this
like baby fire going like just go talk
to her and shauna didn't and they make
you think she did which was brilliant
but her going out there and it really is
what they make you think is a sean a
dream sequence that she feels like you
know she woke up and envisioned
everything just happened with jackie and
seeing laura lee and the mystery guy in
the cabin
but
i again my theory is that it was
jackie's moments before death in her
head and she was experienced with vanda
but the difference between her and
vanna's van lived and jackie died and
that this does have to do with some kind
of supernatural thing kind of getting in
her head during this and i'm gonna say
it has to be addressed you know maybe
you can excuse it with being completely
starving or the supernatural thing
you're possessing jackie but you know
she's freezing to death it's extremely
rare in real life to
sleep through freezing to death that you
would just wake up at some point
freezing cold and she's right next to
the cabin you know so you're kind of
like all right i'll suspend my disbelief
a bit but it is a little silly and
because it's so rare but let me just say
when shauna runs out there and sees
jackie is frozen to death my god the
acting of young shauna should be
applauded that was incredible
and i really think the actress of young
shauna should be nominated for an emmy i
think we've all been talking about the
adult actors here but i think there's so
many you can give it to samantha hanrad
you can give it to ella parnell you can
give it to the actress of sean you give
it to taissa like all of them i could
see the case it's such a strong cast but
really here i think even who stole the
show of the finale was young shauna and
now we see lottie has the bare heart and
she's like now let the darkness set us
free and winter is here it's gonna be so
fascinating what happened with season
two here and who's in what group what's
gonna happen with all these people
knowing secrets in season two and
present day and what's gonna happen with
shauna in the woods because this is
clearly a huge traumatic moment losing
jackie because of the love they had for
each other so and the guilt she's felt
through it so that she is human you know
and i really like that so for me
especially on rewatch is the best
episode of the season for sure i'm
giving this one a 9.5 i'm really
satisfied about this finale now you
might have people wanted more
jaw-dropping moments here they're
waiting for but here's the thing is that
you have to be careful on a show like
this especially in mystery box shows
because if you give
too much of those moments you're kind of
teasing and you know waiting for it's
that catch-string theory with like cats
right where you dangle a toy in front of
them and then they always want to keep
going for it that's us right now but
then the second you give it to them
they're bored by it so it's like they
almost have to wait to have us watching
them eat people and confirm it because
then what you know then we see it and
then it's like okay we're just gonna
watch people eat people like they have
to save stuff and keep you hooked in
that mystery going and i think that's
why i was so smart that they gave us
enough answers here to make it satisfied
produced new questions but made the most
important thing relationships and
characters and that we're gonna get to
that stuff we want right but you have to
hold on to it you gotta make us want to
return it's part of the game here you
know this is classic thing with twin
peaks where it ruined the show when they
revealed
you know who did the murder early on and
that goes to even with things people
wait for in shows that maybe not even
murder mysteries but you know you wanted
jim and pam to get together and then
they get together and then okay cool now
they're together it's just not the same
you missed that chase they had so it's i
think it's the same thing i don't know
that's me though but i thought it was
great and let me know though what you
guys thought of it and i think too i'm
going to get my season score adding this
in you know i think this show deserves
again i would say 8.8 i think that's
fair i think the second half's way
better
i think still that they put way too much
padding in the first couple episodes and
i really am standing out again i can't
get over how bad episode was to me this
is my one gripe it's not all amazing you
know that i mean jesus like we just
watched the whole episode of shauna and
adam on a date so i want i don't feel
like so that was justified at all but
anyway even if they go back to that
again you want more satisfaction in one
season than waiting so that's some of my
qualms but overall the score is
incredible the acting all around i'm
excited it's made such an exciting
community and everyone having their
theories so i'm so happy where this is
going and excited for what's to come
let me know again your theories who you
think should play adult lottie how
you're feeling about the jackie death
are you upset are you does it make sense
to you and please check out my interview
with samantha hanratty who plays misty
quigly i think you're going to enjoy it
it was so much fun she is awesome and
please follow me at steve varley show on
twitter instagram and tick tock for more
of me and please subscribe because i'll
be doing reviews of euphoria next and
other shows as well and i appreciate any
subscribers it helps me so many ways if
you love what i do here become a member
today will help me in so many ways as
well and i'll see you next time